[Music]
i'm tired i really am tired
of hearing about career advancement of
middle-class women like myself or those
who are aiming for the top tables
um crushing this
glass ceilings
um and walking across them in their
stilettos and you know it's not
that's not the struggle i feel most
engaged in it needs to happen it is
happening it's happening too slowly but
what i care about
is how little
mainstream
feminism
looks at the poorest and most
disempowered women
why should they care
about how many women are in the
boardrooms
when those women in the boardrooms or
many of us who have power have never
cared about their lives there's a very
good book written by
nikki kendall
called hood feminism i think it was last
year
and she said this we hear about career
advancement
and dating
while feminist and uh
body hair and last names
but rarely does mainstream feminism
center the conversation on issues that
concern most women
in this country
can they afford food
do they have access to healthcare
are they safe in their homes
do they have homes at all
can they meet all of their basic needs
how can this not be a feminist
issue
um overwhelmingly the answer to the last
question is no
the movement that is supposed to
represent all women
um it's too often not about survival but
about increasing privilege
according to a 2017 report by the food
and agricultural organization of the un
women are more likely to be food
insecure than men in every region of the
world
alleviating a woman's
women's poverty is a critical feminist
issue
and i'm sorry i haven't seen that much
attention
lead to
this critical
uh feminist issue
um and she writes on that same can be
said of gun violence or feminist issue
that is really
taken on by feminists
um the presence of a gun in domestic
violence situation
so she's writing as an american but it
is you know run a lot of young men who
are killing each other
are in single parent households where
the mothers are working three jobs
and i can't understand how we separate
that
from our
emotional commitment to feminism
if feminists care as much about gender
equality as they claim she writes
nikki kendrick
ending the poverty cycle and improving
the quality of life for all women should
be the primary focus and we just
witnessed
in the last year how many female mps
voting against
the basic minimum
lift
in income welfare income
um that that
families depend on
voting against providing school lunches
during holidays women women voting for
this
and i'm sure if we uh you know when the
time comes like sarah vine and like like
uh carrie um johnson they will
grab the feminist ex you know excuse her
mantle
um and ask for our simple being and even
they're not getting it from me
then there's the race and ethnicity
issue
there are multiple layers of
discrimination which
women of color women of disability
lgbt
sexual women
experience and live through and live
with
it's not easy never easy being a black
or brown feminist
out there or within within ourselves
within our families
the the kind of sexism and misogyny
many of us grow up with in the home
um
is
abominable
and it is normative
so that the brother will get the best
bits of the chicken
the brother will never be asked to clear
the table
the brother will never be stopped from
going out when he wants
the the the sister or the daughter will
will wait until the men have eaten and
then get approved even now even in this
country
and i haven't even touched on all those
other awful
injustices like um
on a base abuse and um
fgm
so of course you know there are all
these
layers from layers and
kimberly
trenshaw
was the first to kind of come up with
this very useful term intersectionality
noted that feminists
as feminist efforts focus
more
on the majority white women
in the in the west and downplay the
dimension of race
but she also said something else which
is very important
while anti-racist efforts
impis implicitly center black men
done and downplay the dimension of
misogyny so you can see how hard it is
yeah your anti-racists will often use
male anti-races will not want us to talk
about the misogyny in our communities
that distracts from
the big big
anti-racist
uh struggle of which i am also apart
at the same time
white feminists
maybe through nervousness and i'll come
to that in a minute
kind of want to assume we you know there
are no other additional burdens and
issues
um upon us when they so very often are
just intersectionality is vital
but i don't think that gives us the
license
to behave with wanton aggression
and unfair generalizations about white
women
and that too is happening too much
um i i really struggle with that
i don't think it's fair or right to say
white women if if they try and get
involved are being white saviors
if they don't they don't care
um and there have been two instances
recently where i've been if you like on
the wrong side
um
and i was very proud to be on the wrong
side because i think identity politics
and this kind of division
of
ultimately it's the human agenda as i
said the the commonalities which include
the differences and include awareness
and and honoring the differences but
ultimately we will only win if we go
together
on this comp on this road so there was
this um
uh and still carrying on
a big um
flare-up over the right of kate clancy
um who wrote a book about being a
teacher in an inner city school and it
is a fabulous book it won the overall
prize
somewhere along the line she got
attacked for some of the descriptions
she used um shaped eyes
chocolate colored skin
expressions i use all the time almond
shaped eyes are considered beautiful we
all use it
all indians pakistanis afghanis will use
almond shaped eyes but a white woman
using them was not acceptable but she's
really been put through the mill
um the
girl who she described from afghanistan
says she herself uses that description
but that didn't make me is that these
asian women in
particular really went off
and really destabilized her and i
thought this was completely utterly
unfair and totally self-destructive to
feminism
if we feminists cannot accept that all
of us have the right to interfere in
each other's lives
then we're actually living in a kind of
feminist apartheid and i will not live
in that kind of world
there was a similar
um
theory
when a book was written actually a ring
awful book in my view
um
very shallow
a kind of deliberately incendiary book
titled against white feminism by raphael
zakaria
an american muslim writer
um
she
says you know white feminists are
shallow and consumerist and
don't care about black women and they're
selfish and and then they shouldn't be
interfering and
i i
completely went for her i said you know
you are not writing in the 60s
when all the particularly in the united
states
when there was a moment when it seemed
that
black feminists had to make a really
strong case
um to have their voices heard
we're not living in those times we have
moved into a place you know you look at
the women's apology party
where it is possible
to to become allies and equals doesn't
always happen
but it i don't think
this kind of
um
scapegoating of white feminists who who
wins in the end when they start these
kind of
stupid war feminist laws it's men who
will win always every time
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas
you